nick clegg now a senior figure at
facebook has been doing the rounds on
the sunday programs here in america of
course after that terrible week with
that major
uh outage which saw its platform and
other services such as instagram and
whatsapp down for around six hours then
more problems with those services later
in the week but of course that explosive
testimony from a former facebook
employee turned whistleblower
where she claimed that the company the
social media giant put profits ahead of
people's
safety now nick clegg was responding
directly there to claims uh that they'd
lifted safety measures after the
presidential election last year in the
interest of making more money and that
allegations that that helped incite the
riot on capitol hill and the invasion of
congress on january the 6th something
that nick clegg of course denied there
in that clip but francis haugen this
whistleblower made other allegations too
speaking to the senate based on
information that she claims to have seen
from internal facebook documents now she
claims that facebook is sitting on a
mountain of research on how to keep
people's attention
on the platform for longer by showing
them harmful pro and problematic content
claiming that facebook's own research
looks into how its platforms affects
teenagers how it may amplify hate speech
and misinformation essentially concerns
that parents may have had for years
she's claiming facebook is collecting
data on now nick clegg did offer a great
deal of defense today saying that they
had a significant amount of staff
looking into these safety measures and
that they were going to increase
transparency on its platform increase
safety as well but he also made the
point that with more than a third of the
planet's population using its service it
is very hard to police that content but
by saying that by making that point
he perhaps highlighted the very concern
that so many people have that facebook
wields immense influence nearly three
billion users use its platform and how
is that influence not only monitored but
also used and there's growing calls here
in washington for regulation